Patrick is on now from Florida hey I was
just checking in on our boy JD what
about the LA trip it sounded like he put
a large tab on his credit card JD did
you do some stupid in California no I
got I got money for everybody good
he's getting reimbursed for that so
he'll pay it right off was a expense or
whatever what do you want Ralph
first of all JD said he expense that
dinner if he did that no came back first
so I want my hundred and fifty dollars
for my salad bag
there's a guy that I didn't know he went
to an ATM to give me the money
hold onto that money still I still don't
in there man yeah but do you work with
serious what's that I thought it was
like expensive with people that work
with serious I don't know how all
[ __ ] works oh boy your money back all
right here's how here's how it works if
you got paid back to the dinner then you
owe me $150 which I gave you for the
dinner dummy I actually owe you a
hundred because you can only expense a
hundred so I'll give you $100 let me get
involved in this yeah how much was the
dinner JD forty a person at the table
can I tell you how confusing this is
could st. the same table same dinner
saying Ralph's situation except JD comes
up to me and he goes I think you owe me
$40 right so I say what you think all
right dude you could only expense $100 a
day right dinner was 140 each so JD
collected $40 from each person okay but
he's not sure by 150 come from JD how
come you charge Ralph 150 bucks I didn't
know I thought it was just the people
that worked with in serious I know I
didn't know I don't see Ralph here no JD
when you put in your expense did you
list Ralph as one of the participants
danai just listed who here who is here
so you're not gonna get the full six
hundred back then I don't understand
what did you get what did you get
what do you hate I hate all of this this
R alpha oh you want with the brown pills
if we're just trying to understand the
fine I mean why do you get so threatened
by this okay there was a bill I'm gonna
go over there was a bill at the
restaurant for six hundred let's call it
six hundred how much was the actual bill
it was like six let's say six hundred
and there were six people there our
table it was hey I believe it what's his
fine it was like six it's a hundred
dollars a person buddy alright so let's
say it's a hundred bucks a person so you
said to out give me a hundred fifty
bucks
[ __ ] I didn't want to pay it how do you
know I put the money on my [ __ ] bill
I would have just given it to whoever
else didn't want to [ __ ] do it so I
did it what he should do hopefully he
did it right was he he puts in the $700
expense and he goes I was at dinner with
Jason and will and Sal and a bunch of
other people and he gets all their honey
he gets all their hundred dollars that's
how it's supposed to work this is how
he's buying belts for $200 on my money
also for don't you just pay this up if
you want JD why you giving up no JD
it'll end if I could understand what you
did is Jason right in other words you're
able to say two serious expense me back
to six hundred bucks because I'm taking
Sal's hundred this one's hundred and
that one's right okay
I'm Ralph since he's not part of that
expense account thing you asked him for
a hundred
[Laughter]
I gotta say Brock did get a raw deal